what are your 5 worst screenwriting
habits 5 worst
well it's writing while I'm rewriting
which is running like on a treadmill you
know you can rewrite after you're done
but don't rewrite you know one time I
had a job and the contract stated they
wanted to see every 10 pages and I was
like that's a deal-breaker for me and so
I told my attorney I said I don't want
that as your hire me to write the script
let me write the script that's what it
rewrites about you know you won't know
in 10 pages you know I mean it's like
running on treadmills you know that's
for me a habit that I don't do it's it's
tempting because when you get bored you
scroll back and you're like oh I wonder
what those you know and then you realize
the days go on you're like I should be
on page 15 and I'm on three because I
really you know worked on those three
that's what I rewrite times for another
bad habit
let me see well fear I don't know if
that's a habit but that's a you know
there's a lot of fear involved in
writing you're seen with the blank page
you have to fill and like I've said
before you can alleviate that by having
to solve a treatment which is sort of
your buddy you know and your roadmap and
you won't sit there and just waste time
[Music]
procrastination is another terrible one
and I'm guilty of it as well a bad habit
there's always something to distract you
and then like I said when the writing
gets difficult which it does it's the
easiest time to run away from it and I
found that even when you sit with it
like I think Raymond Chandler said he
sat at his desk every day at the same
time if he if anything happened or it
didn't you know it's that constant
repetition which writing is it's not oh
I'm you know waiting for my muse you
know so I still have to I mean the last
job was procrastinating but I had three
pages a day which was a light schedule
but I found myself on the internet and
looking up stuff and you know
procrastination is horrible what do we
got now three like you're three and
number four I have gotta come up with
two other ones bad habits
let me thank you mean personal habits
screenwriting screenwriting habits over
writing something I don't do but I warn
against it because when I consult on
scripts I read that there's just you
know describing the wallpaper and you
know you have to know what you need to
put in what you need to leave out and I
find a lot of beginning writers you know
hang on so desperately that they're not
going to understand it or that what
can't my you know you know you don't
describe the chandelier unless the
diamonds are part of the heist you know
I mean you start to read people's
clothing and all these and it adds up
and so that's when you end up with 120
page script and why hmm and you look
through and go cut this out it's you
know they don't want to see all this
description and all this stuff and
that's a technique it's to know when to
stay out of the way which is important I
think for writers like you got to know
when when to put your imprint on it but
stay out of the way you know and so what
are we up to four now or four but it's
yes and five what's the other one I
don't know why you can't come within the
fifth that's okay yeah so when you catch
yourself procrastinating do sometimes
just say alright I'm just gonna do it
for a little bit get it out of my system
or what do you do to be your own well
again we're not working alone I used two
years ago have a writing partner you
know so that helps to have somebody go
hey or you're together cuz it's both of
your your collective time you're not
wasting somebody else's time when you're
alone you can waste as much time as you
want right it's just my time but I
usually realize that I'm doing it and
then snap back into like oh I should be
it's it's tough you know distractions
that's why you have to go somewhere
right if you have an office or they have
office spaces now that you can rent yeah
and it's a short-term thing per day and
one time a producer hired me an
assignment and he paid for that office
space so I could go there and it was it
was something about like
when I go to the gym you made a
commitment to take that trip to get
there and park and so you're gonna be
productive rather than working at home
when there's a lot of distractions if
you have a family somebody knocking door
phone ringing other times I've worked at
a library you know and when it's quiet
and things like that so your work
environment is also very important to
fight off the forces of procrastination
yeah the whole co-working cultures is
very interesting yeah what about over
writing I was wondering if you could
maybe just give me an example of
something that's overwritten versus
shortening it down well mainly it's in
descriptions in the script but also over
writing the dialogue you know where you
could go through and in a piece you
could say you don't need that beginning
sentence you know you're saying the same
thing in repetition two lines from now
you know really getting concise down to
the point of having or overriding where
characters say something and you could
say it would be better if they just had
a reaction you know I always try to err
on the side of let it let the actors act
and emote rather than say something you
know if you see someone's eyes 60 feet
on the screen that's gonna say a lot
more than a line of dialogue you know so
you cut cut cut cut cut cut they say cut
the dialogue and then cut it 20 percent
more than that you're like oh lean and
no one wants to because but I've read
screenplays that read like a stage play
and you're like that's not that's not
what this is or scenes every director
I've worked with said give me something
to shoot where the scene is just
flattens and two people sitting that
Quentin Tarantino can do it with the
interesting dialogue with ten pages of
dialogue but two characters sitting in
the dinner scene you know the directors
I worked with is they hate it they're
lazy what are we doing it's just this
this this you know and plus the food
would be spoiled you know it's it takes
a long time to film it you know so yeah
the in overwriting the descriptions like
I said before about describing things
there that are not your job you know you
just set the scene if it's a castle you
don't have to say and all the
intricacies
the interior of the castle and in the
corner there's a knight in shining armor
and there's a thing in the tapestry the
set designer will will do that you know
you have to you have to stand back and
and in in a way you have to really know
what what you need to put in it's
necessary and what is unnecessary and I
think a lot of beginning writers don't
know that that fine line and they just
put everything in it you know and so if
someone were to read it and it drags
would they know let's suppose it's their
work and they think oh no but I'm
describing this interaction between two
people and the tension and it's great
but then an outside person is looking at
it saying this is dragging yeah cut to
the chase what's going on you know less
is always more is you know what I mean
and I've always found that and you find
some producer I worked with he caught
the repetition and dialogue and I didn't
even see it and he said you're saying
the same thing here again we don't need
it I'm like oh my god you're right and
he's a big anti repetition you know
producer and I've never had that before
a producer like would point out those
specifics like oh you're right I've got
this bad habit now of not even seeing it
and so now I'm very cognizant of that
when I work with him and in general that
you know we only have so much time on
the screen and so many pages and and if
you don't like the constraints then
write a novel we can do whatever you
want but if you like the screenplay
format you know you have to have these
dense packed scenes with subtext but not
go on for six eight pages you know
there's a rhythm to it you have a feel
like you say when you start reading that
the scripts overwritten and you just
know everything's described in the
writers so afraid to let go that they're
their vision or their ideas won't come
through on the page well once they take
that script and make it yeah but you
want to you know your imprint is the
script so you know all these other
little particulars are not going to help
when it's overwritten
you